non en fait non je préfère te vois tu je
préfère parler d'une gueule moi même
pour le voir minutes médias j'aurais
fait un truc à part a cédé ouais pas mal
ont tout de suite c'est le 20h médias
puis à votre place et vous vous lancez
juste un truc quand vous serez
producteurs l'instant à livrer des
fruits et légumes donc avec l'ema
minutes médias ce soir trois sujets
boyard landes l'émission la plus éclatée
du paf
à qui la faute élections us retour sur
le week end ras sera de donald trump et
bien sûr on en rappelant d'image plein
d'infos et mas singer est ce que c'est
la honte de participer à l'émission moi
je dis non personnellement et on aura
bien une folie qui sera avec nous nous
dire est ce que vous en pensez
sérieusement samedi dernier lance de
lancer sa deuxième saison de bois
garlande la version divers de fort
boyard qui se déroule dans un parc
d'attractions l'émission c'est son
retour avec une spéciale halloween
une semaine après halloween ce toujours
bien d'arriver dans les temps
toujours bien c'est à dire tu fais noël
tu fais noël le 3 janvier quand tu vois
c'est vrai c'est noël avait trouvé
qu'elle sortait une fois passé le 3
janvier et ça a été une catastrophe
industrielle pour la chaîne qui se
retrouvent cinquièmes des eaux dont 1,3
million de téléspectateurs pour moi
irlande j'ai toutes les infos sur boya
relance bien sûr et bossi je voulais
donner dans un instant boilard landes
qui est bien sûr battu par matt singer
par commissaire magellan qui est en
rediffusion ce rookie en été ou 1 0 qui
la fit de vache le 5 millions de
téléspectateurs
et ça même été battus on l'a échappé
belle 65 sur le mérite
échappé belle magnifique émission alors
ça a été tourné sur une ancienne base de
loisirs à boran sur oise près de paris
les décors sont démontées une fois le
tournage terminé ça coûte plaint un
petit lyncheurs ça coûte une dingue
regardez les chèques industrielle de
briare landes et on a toutes les infos
dans le magnéto on wendel après on vous
donne mais nous dit même combien coûte
boyard londres regardez
face au succès que rencontrent les
missions davanture fort boyard depuis
des décennies france 2 a eu l'idée dé
tirer le format en créant une version
dérivée poyart landes
le parc d'attractions renvoie ses portes
pour une soirée des plus offrir un
programme diffusé l'hiver de façon à
être présents toute l'année à l'antenne
6 600 mille euros ont été investis dans
chaque prime de ce jeu le public lui ne
semble pas avoir investi le jeu samedi
ils étaient seulement 9% devant le
programme un million trois cent mille
téléspectateurs
un échec qui embarrasse france 2 la
chaîne a encore en magasin cinq épisodes
à diffuser et ne sait plus quoi en faire
il faut dire que le jeu a de quoi
dérouter les fans de fort boyard avec
des règles parfois incompréhensibles
trouver les solutions pour atteindre le
wagon où se cache l'ombre sous une
lumière qui laisse parfois à désirer et
des sketches écrits avec les pieds trois
fois de trouver ça fait ça fait
citrouille ou son compte et que côté
casting c'est la foire aux miss mesdames
et messieurs bienvenue et animations
retrouve camille ses rangs foraine après
delphine wespiser qui interprète rouge
dans fort boyard une impression de déjà
vu
d'autant que côté candidats on
retrouvait également sylvie tellier et
clémence bottineau miss france 2020
autant se dire qu'on se croyait sur tf1
un soir d'élection je ferai de mon mieux
serait téméraire courageuse g20 premier
peur vous pourrez compter sur moi alors
brouillard landes émission la plus
éclatée du pape
hadji la pause
alors la plus éclatée devenir la plus
pourrie nous c'est pas bon alors arrêt
pour moi l'émission elle est clairement
bidon de a à z déjà alloué non le fait
pas une semaine après surtout pas en
france parce que les français n'ont rien
à faire de cette fête on n'est pas en
amérique
donc ce n'est pas le même truc est
franchement cette lenteur de l'émission
même les candidats ils sont clairement
chier donc j'aime pas du tout nicolas
pernikoff pourquoi cet échec est ce que
vous l'auriez mis à l'antenne de france
télévisions non moi j'aurais pas bien à
l'antenne
c'était troublant parce qu'en fait il se
passait rien n'y avait pas de promesses
alors pourquoi mettre boyard c'est très
dangereux quand même marketing mans
parce que la promesse fort boyard fort
boyard vous savez chaque été ça fait
rêver quand même des des millions de
gens là ça n'avait rien à voir avec fort
boyard
en réalité il y avait pas eu toute cette
magie de fort boyard et puis un peu là
on peut se faire peur en regardant fargo
arles et et ça c'était complexe avait
complètement disparu
et puis c'était un non événement parce
qu'ils avaient rien il se passait rien
c'est donc je sais pas quoi vous dire
il ne se passait rien alors il
paraîtrait que c'est la première saison
coûté 750 kg le bout et après
amortissement cette saison six cent
mille euros l'émission c'est beaucoup
c'est un fan de france 2 c'est énorme
énorme donc à laon avis la chaîne doit
être embarrassée
maintenant il ya une bonne nouvelle lui
demander de nous et ça c'est que
derrière laurent ruquier a fait 725
téléspectateurs ça veut dire qu'il veut
il n'a pas besoin de me dire que les
exactement ce qui veut dire que les
téléspectateurs commencent à l'avenir
pour le rendez-vous denrées en embrasser
la bonne ailleurs et je suis content
pour lui parce qu'il a fait un beau
score samedi soir et une autre émission
qui a fait un beau score c'est vendredi
- émission qu'il adore la boîte à
secrets et qu'est ce qui vous rend
commandes et qui a prévu des camions de
plus de 8 en sciences dures pour moi ça
c'est une belle émission
et ça il faut vraiment recommandé plus
si j'ai un conseil à donner à france 3
et je vous le dis alors je vous dis je
suis pas du tout producteur de la boîte
à secrets voulais je voudrais à rire
mais non mais on vous dira benjamin oui
vous le dire aux téléspectateurs pas de
jeu et même nicolas où vous lire je suis
quand même je dis la vérité puisque la
boîte à secret c'est pas du tout dans
mon groupe
alors que fort boyard louis masson
déficit c'est mon nom voilà ce qui
marche pas marche pas il faut souhaiter
entre nous et essayer de comprendre
pourquoi on est là en plus d'écrans par
idra pression par rapport aux joies de
la chaîne on sait que boyard ça ne
marche jamais en dehors de juillet août
à chaque fois la série à chaque fois ils
font des saisons qui s'étire sur
septembre ça ne fonctionne pas il avait
essayé rappelez vous de lancer boya on
est en hiver il a été la catastrophe et
c'était une catastrophe accusent les
gens ont envie de voir se tenir chaud
pour juillet août et surtout c'est vrai
que c'est une marque forte boyals en
symboles et en tous les cas et c'est
très risqué de le ce programme
honnêtement il est rare et c'est mal
écrit
les jeux sont pour et il en reste cinq à
dix fait forcément ça va être
déprogrammée on sait pas où ils vont
mettre un france 2 non mais je vous dis
ça prouve encore ils vont le mettre
ils vont changer en tout cas que samedi
soir pourrait le mettre sur france 4
rien n'y avait pas prévu
non non non il le vers youtube en séries
tu dis non non c'est parce que c'est
beaucoup trop cher si ça ils peuvent pas
mais si on descend si la palme est un
autre jour que le samedi apparemment et
ils vont essayer d'écouler les 5
derniers épisodes et puis bien sûr y
aura pas de troisième série ça me
l'employeur mais oui ça ne peut pas
marcher cessé entre fort boyard
intervilles mais fort boyard semble fort
et intervilles sans les villes et les
riches est donc nettement salle afin de
passer comme moteur sur les mains c'est
des épreuves en toc des candidats en
bois et des audiences en carton c'était
prévisible et le pire de tout le pire de
tout c'est les intervenants milieu comme
notamment camille serme le truc c'est le
programme et la gentille n'a rien à voir
pour moi la sauvette programme mais vous
occultez vous êtes un bon camarade c'est
une miss casa pas talent non il se
trouve que je suis franchement c'est pas
mal c'est juste que je pense qu'ils se
trompent de chêne faut mettre ça sur une
autre chaîne parce que quand les
participants s'appelle monsieur
moustache et s'est passé quoi le sucre
as la seconde passe nulle part on dirait
une émission qui est sur gulli à savoir
que les 600 mille euros sur gulli
non mais les participants plus ne sont
pas payés quand comme tu devras
diversion c'est sûr et c'est très
intuitif on nage c'est de 17 heures à 4
heures du matin c'est tournez la nuit
c'est très casse il ya mon ami et
magloire mais c'est vrai que ces casques
sont débordés voilà c'est des gens quand
on leur dit le confinement ceux du bon
ça change pas grand chose n'a pas non
plus changé ma vie quoi jamais 26% j'ai
pas aimé 74 passoire